the Upper House of Russia's Parliament
has approved the claimed annexation of
four regions in Ukraine the legislation
will go to the Kremlin for the final
stamp by President Vladimir Putin the
new law is being pushed through despite
the U.N and Western allies insisting
it's illegal it formally incorporates
Curson zabarija Donetsk and luhansk into
the Russian Federation it's based on the
results of referendums held just over a
week ago
Muhammad Val joins us now from Moscow so
the annexation of the four regions has
been signed off uh what happens next
uh yes Tom what happens next as you
mentioned after the the final stop of
President Vladimir Putin this is going
to become the newest the latest
Constitutional Amendment whereby
Russia's map is going to change and in
new regions for new entities are going
to be added to the Russian Federation
raising the number of entities republics
and departments or regions from 85 to 89
this is very crucial in terms of how the
Russians look at the war that is going
on but also what happens next is that
Russia has officially
announced the annexation of regions that
it doesn't control a hundred percent
for Donetsk and lugansk they said that
the the borders will be the same as the
borders of 2014 before the start of the
of the conflict there and for uh for
zapposia and
her son it's not even clear even the
Russian leadership has uh not given a
precise borderline when it was asked
about it and they said it is going to be
left for uh consultations with local
people there so I mean it's it's
interesting that Russia has a next
territory that it doesn't know where it
ends and uh foreign minister Sergey
lavrov said something very interesting
yesterday after immediately after the
vote in the in the lower house they were
they were applauding and he he said and
this is not going to be the last time
you vote on something like this one of
the MPS asked him is this something
between the lines and he said no this is
clear so I mean the implication there is
that uh you know it's open open to
interpretations is it is he talking only
about zapposia and uh and and her son or
is he talking about future annexations
probably not only inside Ukraine but
also in other areas around Russia uh
interesting time for Russia because this
coincides with those clear defeats that
the Russian army has received in the
front line and lots of criticism here on
Russian TV and by people who are very
close to President Vladimir Putin about
the performance of the Russian army so
Russia has this big challenge it has
given a huge hope to its to its people
that now the Empire has become greater
but at the same time it is unable to
even defend the territory that it has
already controlled okay thank you so
much this Muhammad Val for us in Moscow
where Ukrainian forces have achieved a
significant breakthrough in the South
that have pushed through Russian
defenses and advanced along the danipro
river Kiev released this video showing
soldiers in a newly retaken Village the
games could threaten supply lines for
thousands of Russian troops
today the offensive movement of our army
and Defenders continued there are new
liberated settlements in several regions
this fighting continues in many areas on
the front line but more and more
occupiers are trying to escape the enemy
Army is suffering more and more losses
and there is a growing understanding
that Russia made a mistake by starting
the war against Ukraine Rory challenge
is life for us and Kevin just how much
ground have Ukrainian forces been able
to retake
well look I think I think today
militarily in Ukraine feels like one of
those days kind of between uh the big
days the weekend was huge because of the
fall of Lee man yesterday uh was big
because of that breakthrough in the
Hearthstone region today feels like a
little bit of a lull but that is
probably misleading because the
ukrainians actually have pretty good
operational security this idea that
while uh things are hot the fighting is
going on uh that you keep a lid on
information there are no careless tweets
uh or selfies or telegram posts but we
know that both of those operations are
ongoing we heard there from president
zielinski uh saying that you know the
the taking back of territories is now a
trend and he talks about various
settlements in various regions being
regained but he left it vague
interestingly a lot of the information
that we are getting on this is coming
from Russian sources Russian military
sources and they are saying that down in
the south in the Hesson region Uh
Russian forces have retreated uh as much
as well 30 35 kilometers from the front
lines as they were a couple of days ago
uh they're now in the village of decheni
uh in the Herson region some sources
actually saying they've pulled back
further than that another 15 kilometers
or so down the West Bank of the NEPA
River and we also hear from these
Russian sources that the ukrainians now
have their sights uh way up in the east
of the country uh after taking liman on
the towns of svato and cremina another
thing that the Russian sources have
noticed is that the tactics of the
ukrainians are you know when they meet
any kind of stiff resistance
but don't try and Blast away at it and
suffer attritional losses what the
ukrainians do is they look for weak
points and they try and circumvent those
strongholds those Russian strongholds
and because of this months-long campaign
that the ukrainians have of striking
rear areas hitting supply lines hitting
Russian command posts at the moment
because of the sheer size of the front
lines and the condition of the Russian
forces there are many many weak points
for the for the ukrainians to exploit
okay thank you very much that's very
challenged in cave